on a appris que deux candidats qui ont
participé au tournage de l'édition 2018
annulé après l' affaire de viol qu'elle
dans koh lanta qui dira toujours en
cours de justice où en cours deux
enquêtes vont ont été repêchés le
problème quel est le problème qui
l'attend est bien là le problème c'est
que par rapport à cette saison un nul il
y en a deux qui faisait donc partie de
cette saison qui finalement été recruté
pour la nouvelle saison qui arrive alors
là il ya deux éléments cd alexia laroche
joubert qui est la productrice de
l'émission s'était engagé petit à petit
au fil des saisons à reprendre ses
anciens candidats qui finalement sont
restés que quinze jours dans cette
saison qui est annulé donc là voilà
certains disent non il fallait pas les
reprendre parce qu'ils ont déjà eu entre
guillemets à leur chance et d'autres
disent bah oui ils ne sont pour rien
dans cette histoire mais il fallait les
reprendre pour cette nouvelle saison
justement alors visiblement ils ont ils
n'auraient pas pu se rapprocher les uns
des autres on aurait donné des fausses
adresses e-mail qu'il ya une histoire
autour de ça oui il ya effectivement eu
toute une polémique autour de ça mais
après ce vraiment d'excellents joubert
c'est sûr ça qui elle insiste vraiment
c'est que ces personnes n'y sont pour
rien par rapport à raison supposée
agression de radio qui me fait avancer
alors là la question c'est est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée de réintégrer deux
candidats qui ont partiellement
participer à une saison qui a été
apportée ou pas oui bah pour moi oui
associé au contraire c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment pour rien dans cette histoire
les rouages ils ont déjà fait le
naufrage des saisons précédentes ils
connaissent encore plus les rouages
encore plus le métier donc dans ces cas
là autant marciac avec des anonymes qui
n'ont que jamais non ça va être une très
grande frustation frustration des
touristes russes rémunération comprise
ont tourné une émission telle que koh
lanta les gens qui vont faire koh lanta
veulent vraiment faire koh lanta et je
pense avec très dur pour eux à face à
dieu et dur pour eux à vivre que ça
s'arrête comme ça qui est pas de fin et
ils doivent être aujourd'hui frustré je
trouve ça très humain de la part des
l'excès laroche joubert justement de les
réintégrer au ferme isolée pas de les
avoir abandonnés d'avoir dures vases on
laisse tomber on passe à autre chose
parce que pour son image à elle quelque
part c'est remettre en danger parce
qu'on reparle de cette affaire donc elle
nous donne des outils pour reparler de
cette affaire qui est pas super
florissante pour elle donc c'est se
mettre en danger pour une question
humaine jeu franchement bravo elle est
ce que ce n'est pas une façon de
euh faire un peu de buzz autour de
l'émission et dans ce cas précis c'est
pas forcément un très beau jeu d'école
d'avis pour moi c'est on est entre les
deux il ya un peu de buzz quand même
tout a été fait pour qu'on reparle un
petit peu de koh lanta
il ya eu pas mal de problèmes ces
dernières années sur un koh lanta c'est
peut-être un moyen de communiquer un peu
plus sur l'émission
vous pensez que ça va pas trop l'intérêt
de réintégrer des candidats je comprends
ce que vous ne l avez ramené l'idée de
vue d'accords
vous savez très bien que ces émissions
ça va très très vite on passe d'une
saison et notre les spectateurs maîtrise
aujourd'hui c'est une des productrices
qui va jusqu'au bout c'est à dire
qu'enfin il y en a d'autres
il ya plein de trucs productrice mais
elle fait partie des gens qui m'ont dit
plusieurs fois à moi qui gère
aujourd'hui candidat attention c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai intégré en télé je
veux le protéger je veux y faire
attention
je veux elle elle se mêle remet pas en
cause son mérite est là et gagner
lorsqu'un article en contre avec est-ce
que si vous aviez été en place à tf1
vous auriez accepté que dans le casting
nouvelle saison on réintègre ceux qui
ont été dans une saison d'avoir moi je
n'aurais pas fait pour une raison simple
alors après le producteur pour y
défendre des choses mais c'est le buzz
c'est le buzz c'est le buzz autour c'est
cette bête de regarder le bad buzz c'est
pas génial koh lanta c'est quand même
une émission très familial qui marche
très bien pourquoi faire parler de
revenir téféciste forcément on reparle
encore du viol on reparle du viol par
tous bien mais entre le dire ça marche
bien elle n'a pas besoin donc tu te
contredis tout seul
là où tous les cas tous les cas on va
suivre ça commence bientôt la saison de
koh lanta la wii ça commence dans quinze
jours aucun jour ok merci beaucoup